it's time for hatred mail and if you've
never heard hatred mail before I got a
lot of hate mail hey treat male is when
my hate mail is interpretive Lee read by
a deep voice movie announcer in the
following style because we cling to our
guns and our God but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to
assault our wife Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom alright a
lot of homophobia directed at me and
hatred mail but I have not before been
called a lesbian during hatred mail
although there is a first time for
everything and the first time for that I
guess is today the left is just so
stupid on this issue including this
lesbian named David Pakman you are a
disgrace
gurbles would be proud David and silly
liberals facts don't care about your
feelings hey David
Argentina sucks oh Moo gosh you solved
it David oh yeah it's all clear now yes
sell our souls to the Communists
Marxists yeah okay it's so funny that I
keep being attacked as a communist or
Marxist or social or socialist while at
the same time being attacked by the
actual Socialists who were angry that
I'm not a socialist I'm taking it from
both sides simultaneously on that it's a
new critique every day and I just think
it's rude it's completely hatred mail is
one of the rudest segments I've ever
experienced on the program in addition
to being called a titmouse by one of the
people from that Westboro Baptist Church
once that I've even mean that's it it's
a little bird it's a little tip Mouse as
a bird which I guess I'm chirping you
know like weekly I think was the idea
sort of like to attack my manhood in
some way it could be a compliment to I'm
somewhat peaceful creature to the tip
house that I find to be a completely
sort of regal bird for sure yeah and I
know nothing about birds whatsoever
if you want to make 18 hey tree it's cry
send them a middle finger by using the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you sign
up for a membership at www
join pakman.com you save 40% and 18
hatreds cry